today marks the first day of black
history month a time for celebration and
education of african american culture
authors ibram x kendi and kisha blaine
are releasing a new book called
400 souls a community history of african
america
1619-2019
the anthology features essays from 90
writers and poets
who each focus on a specific period of
time
keisha blaine is an historian and
professor at the university of
pittsburgh
and cbs news contributor ebra max kendy
is the founding director of the boston
university center
for anti-racist research they join us
first
on cbs this morning welcome to you both
congratulations thank you so much for
being here
ibram let me start with you because this
is a book that has as i pointed out
of 90 different authors a variety of
voices
why was it important that you use so
many authors
well in in in 2018 i was
thinking about what would be the best
way to commemorate
this 400th birthday symbolic birthday of
black america this
this this community and as an historian
of course i was
like well let's let's write a history
book
but then the more that i thought about
it the more i realized well why not
bring together a community to write the
history
of a community and and so of course i
had to reach out to to professor blaine
who who was willing to partner with me
um
and and we were able to do that bring
together an incredible community of
writers to write a history of a
community
kisha you say that you wanted to
challenge the idea
that the black community is a monolithic
community
yes i think this is so important because
of course we
may look similar but we're not the same
there's so much diversity of thought and
diversity of experiences and even
diversity backgrounds
and it was important for us to represent
that
richness and complexity in the way that
we told
the history in 400 souls you know i
thought was interesting
number one i want to thank you both for
having short chapters
it was such a great read because you
could zip through it very quickly so i
thank you for that
number two there were so many stories i
didn't know hugh davis was one that
stuck out to me
was a white man who was beaten because
he had slept with a
with a black woman and it that was an
interesting twist in what the stories
that we've been told in the past
why did you include that professor
well yeah it was an incredible essay by
oh yeah you're both professor
sorry
he was beaten for dishonoring whiteness
and nothing happened to her
go ahead professor kennedy first
no i was just going to say very quickly
i mean idioma's piece was
was incredible but i think it really
speaks to
how old racism is
is in what later became america and even
how old black women have been
sort of devalued uh you know in america
yeah that was in 1630. i like to
professor blaine where you said
i am my ancestors wildest dreams that is
absolutely one of my favorite sayings
why is that so powerful
it's so powerful because it speaks to
all that
i think we've overcome certainly as
individuals
but but even collectively as black
people
because certainly if you look back at
the history and you reflect on even the
time period that we're discussing
now you would really have to marvel
at what black people have managed to
accomplish given
uh the experiences of slavery jim crow
and the continued challenges of racism
and white supremacy
another uh story that that i think uh is
not familiar to a lot of people is about
maria stewart who was a feminist
feminist and
an abolitionist in boston in the 1830s
why why did you choose to include her
story
her story is so powerful because it
resonates uh with the present in many
ways especially when we think about
for example the black lives matter
movement we think about the courageous
uh three black women who found
the movement and we saw just in the last
couple of months with the uprisings how
black women have played such a pivotal
role
in shaping american politics and mariah
stewart's story from the 1830s
help us recognize that this is certainly
not a new uh phenomena that black women
have been leading for a very long time
and they have been asserting their
voices
and demanding rights for themselves and
also demand rights for everyone
and as we mark black history month it
always sticks in my call that it's the
shortest month of the year but that's
another story
what do you want people to know what
what should we remember and take from
this month as we begin to honor and
observe and celebrate
professor kendy well i i think this
history book
really demonstrates that there are so
many
individuals historical figures that we
should continue
to revere but we should also not forget
those
ordinary black folks who
have been part of this longer struggle
and so we were very
keen on on bringing in stories of
everyday black folks who
who who strove to be free throughout the
course of their history
yeah i like to think of it as american
history uh professor blaine you want to
take us off
it's american history i think and it's
really important to
remember and and just reflect on the
strength and resilience
of black people in the united states as
people read the book they'll see
the challenges that black people faced
but just the way that they found uh they
were able to overcome those challenges
and the way that they were able
uh to move things forward and really to
make
uh the nation a better place for all of
us even though the work and the struggle
still continues
yeah i'm looking at this thank you both
you said the book shows that black
people never stop dreaming or fighting
for their dreams to become a
reality and certainly some of that
continues today i'm going to hold up the
book if you don't mind
ibra mex kindy and keisha blaine we
thank you both 400 souls goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books